de la frontière il voit régulièrement
passer des migrants derrière sa maison
il croit que les changements annoncés
vendredi ne les découragerons pas
se trouve la ville de placeburg les
migrants se rendant au Canada ne font
que passer mais l'annonce de la
fermeture du chemin Roxane suscite des
questions
facile encore de dire si un afflux de
migrants aux États-Unis est à prévoir
ici le scénario de 1987 pourrait se
répéter
le Canada avait alors refoulé un grand
nombre de migrants qui ne savait plus où
aller explique ce membre de l'Église
presbytérienne des familles ont logé
dans l'église pendant des mois
de 1987 à 1992 si l'histoire se répète
une chambre pourrait être aménagée ici
on ne sait pas combien de personnes ont
été refoulées par le Canada en vertu des
nouvelles règles Nice qui leur adviendra
une fois aux États-Unis ici Marie
Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada plats